bonjour ne triche pour la rai algérien
sera toi
vous êtes tombés dans l'oubli à gauche
j'ai vaucluse en le truc d'or sur le
coop et tout ce qui est réalisé soit
celle qui est à l'extrême gauche le
voile est levé il avec les gens qui
voient là le grave est tombé en panne et
le truc dont nous avons des sens
on écoute pour ainsi rural autant les
uns groupe lente l'alignement évêques
avec pelé le bim et que nous les là
derrière
sort de l'entendement
non mais faut couper heureux
pour cent
et là je veux quoi on n'est pas ce que
c'est le père surtout souffre et ses
parts n'ont pas trop à gauche parce
qu'il ya toute la foule qui s'est agi
bord de couple je crois qu'on a un truc
là
ok
allez
dehors